well now a final exclusive poll looking
ahead to next week's election tonight
our 8 news now Emerson College at the
hill research focuses on the race for
governor and what matters most to voters
politics now hosts Chung Langer takes a
closer look
[Music]
this poll was taken at the end of
October right as early voting started
here in Nevada it shows Republicans
leading most of the major races
including the contest for governor it's
been close since the primaries wrapped
up Governor Steve sisilak trying to hold
off Republican Clark County Sheriff Joe
Lombardo however as the race has dragged
on polls show it's the Challenger with
the advantage our new exclusive 8 news
now Emerson College the hill poll shows
Lombardo leading by Four Points 49 to 45
percent both candidates have gained
since our last poll in September and
undecided voters are down to just 3
percent since our first poll in June you
can see how voters moods have shifted
while Lombardo held steady before
jumping up in October Governor sisalak
has gone up and down polling also shows
Governor sisalak losing among Latino
voters in the race for the open Nevada
Secretary of State Post just two points
separate the main contenders Republican
Jim Marchant has 43 percent Democrat
Cisco Aguilar 40 31 percent Democrat
attorney general Aaron Ford leads his
re-election bid 45 to 40 percent over
Republican Segal Chata one thing which
has stayed steady from the very
beginning though the issues that matter
most to nevadans as they vote this
November polling shows it's the economy
on their minds 46 percent say it's the
top issue with threats to democracy a
distant second as always they're just
polls only on November 8th do these
numbers become Real Results John langler
8 News Now